hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the video where I'm going
to be reacting to my old videos I still
got a few days left on my baby face
before my beard blooms gloriously so I
thought the last thing I do would be
really plague me to watch some of my
older videos and kind of look back at
the mixture of cringy stuff alongside
the stuff that I'm actually legitimately
proud of like I I always like to look
back because it reminds me of how far
I've come and also it reminds me of oh
god why did I do that thing oh that was
me oh god join me on this adventure
because the first ones a real banger of
a video I lick this on Twitter just
yesterday and that's what got me the
idea to do this uh yeah I don't know why
I made this I can't even get my thought
process behind it so I'm just gonna play
it and you yeah
[Music]
hi my name is markiplier now I'm here to
teach you how to smash a bottle get your
head first empty bottle ah Len whoo huh
boy oh boy oh boy okay we need to talk
about this one because there's a lot of
things to go through here okay so first
off I want to reiterate this video if
you've noticed the 30 second videos that
I've been doing nowadays it's the same
mindset that I was doing these videos
back then it's like I know it's stupid
I know it's stupid I did it knowing that
it was dumb and my god look at my hair I
don't know why I paused it I mean I
can't exactly complain why because if we
look back at a video that I did just a
few months ago I mean the only
difference is that it's better made
literally I took all the skills that
I've learned in the four and a half
years I've been doing YouTube and I made
an equally stupid video just in a
different way there's a live stream
going on right now and you're not
watching it watching and that was it cuz
I used to make these stupid videos like
when we were doing live streams on
Twitch
I would make a video on YouTube to tell
people I'm live on Twitch because like
the notification system wasn't very good
and yet like I this is still up here
like so if someone watched it like
what's what the [ __ ] are they looking at
like why is this a more lies okay
apparently it is the first vlog I've
ever done I don't remember if that's
true but it's the first vlog in the vlog
playlist so this is the first time I did
a vlog I'm not even looking at the
camera when I start out hello everybody
today is my birthday
yeah I'm 23 today so I suppose cause for
some celebration but I also wanted to
take a moment to you know thank you guys
as I usually do I don't thank you guys
enough I don't get it you know even
though I thank you every the end of
every single video that's still not
enough because you guys are done a
tremendous job of getting my new channel
back on its feet let me give you some
more statistics just oh yeah I used to
talk about the statistic slow why did I
do that God why did I wait look you guys
don't care about the numbers mind if the
numbers are meaningless yeah but sad
that's so low okay what about what am i
sad about and I guess Oh 56 shares
I guess you're into different mechanic
but god but sad that's so low but that's
okay I just passively aggressively being
like Machir so low it's okay I guess but
whatever you know it's it if you guys
don't want to share it try I guess to be
over here in the not share corner [ __ ]
it off I have a job for you guys if
you're interested in doing it
go find a friend tie them to a chair
bound and gag them roll them up to your
computer and play all my videos so that
I said this exact same thing in the
tuber simulator video oh man I totally
forgot about that it's never enough
I need more subscribers all the time
more people tied to chairs is find
someone make them subscribe time new
chair sign them up to youtube you know
do everything again I'm just joking
that's is fun you don't have to do that
but thanks you don't have to do that you
don't got to do that but you really need
to do that you told it's my birthday
I needed give it to me give me that I
want it and I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye bye it's so adorable
I mean talking about myself I'm not
durable whatever bugged me man trying
new things was always a part of it
because I had no idea what I was doing
like I I had to try new things cuz like
no one was giving me a guy no one had a
guide to be a big youtuber and then like
god [ __ ] there it is holy [ __ ] this is
uh I wanted it all jeez I wanted to have
like a sense of professionalism in my
videos which I don't know why I wanted I
didn't want that at all I also got this
Hello Kitty rainbow tiara thingy that I
found on the street vendor some poor guy
was handing out and I chopped them with
my accent oh I also have this master the
universe noisemaker here do do I ever
blink am I ever gonna like oh so nervous
oh god I was so nervous action quality
on my V log so they don't know V whoa
wait a minute hold on my V log so they
don't they're not just some fiction
quality on my V logs my V logs my V log
she's Paul D on my V log so that
something alive Lulu what were the
entertainment oh good call dear anyway
oh Jesus
quality entertainment quality
entertainment cuz when people think of
markiplier they think of quality
entertainment I was so nervous like
unbelievably nervous because I was like
this has got to be good it's got to be
nice everyone's gonna love it everyone's
gonna appreciate it and like at the time
like it got a good response like I was
like and then I was like yeah that's the
way to do it that's good yeah I think it
was just like I will feel sorry for this
this awkward nerd here what a nerd shut
up you nerd all of you beautiful people
in there we can actually make a
difference if we can unite the time
behind a common goal and believe that
gaming is actually an important part of
our world and is going to change society
in the years to come that's what I
believe and that's what I'm gonna push
and that's what I want to be a part of
and I want to make you a part of that as
well
so yeah man I had such high hopes
as a kid as a kid it's when I was 23
well its way through you know I can't
four years ago I still do god I still do
okay I'm so proud of everything that
we've done I'm so proud of like how far
we've come and we're gonna get back into
the monthly live streams that's one of
the reasons why Tyler is here now
because he's also going to be helping me
do that and we're gonna be doing monthly
live streams right now we've been doing
weekly live streams as part of like you
know uh just stuff we're doing on
YouTube primetime but then after that
we're gonna be doing monthly charity
livestreams we're gonna get be getting
back in that swing of things I want to
bring you know Wade and Bob out here
again to be able to be a part of it you
know have like a central camping ground
for this to happen like I want it again
and it's like it's one of those things
where you're like I want that and then
I'm like I have to go like just stupid
piece of [ __ ] you can do it now dad I
just [ __ ] do it it's like hell yeah
I'm gonna do it site man what is up with
the color wall hello everybody ah
why are here I just want holy [ __ ]
hanging I got a dude go back at that
again hi hello everybody what does five
here I just wanted to do quick v-log to
answer some questions they love people
be logs I just wanted to do cook v-log
to answer some questions that some
people have assembled for me I don't
know what was up with my lighting yeah I
look like a baked potato put a wig on me
and maybe I could run for president but
my god blue oh no oh no hi my name is
markiplier last week I lost a bet to you
guys and and I've decided that I'm going
to try to twerk twerk three things like
close the right music
honestly that was perfectly acceptable
music Joyce okay
damn I mean honestly it's kind of
impressive I'm not gonna deny not really
it's not impressive at all this is
[ __ ] oh god this is the stupidest
thing I've ever done yeah yeah it is
yeah it's it's pretty damn stupid yeah
why did I do that oh my god that's there
forever
ah it's something forever I can never
run for political office not that I'd
want to because that exists this is
gonna be like I'm gonna be on a debate
and somebody's gonna watch this video
this idiot over here and I'm gonna be
like yep okay I concede I give up right
I am an idiot I see that now it's very
clear idiot right right up there okay Oh
monster Puppet Pals Oh bother about the
bells why hasn't my what blows as many
videos today it's because YouTube is
being slow and taking forever with long
videos well I hey what's that over there
wouldn't what a wall yeah no not this
again I got a lot of toys back when I
sell out a peel box before everything
got way too much and I wasn't able to
handle anything and I got toys in there
it was like a handmade amnesiac running
a ham made and CP 173 it's just super
adorable and I thought the - I I like
this video I'm still happy with this
video I'm totally okay with this video
even though you can see the crest of my
hair like a shark in the water peering
up above the screen there hello
everybody we just hit 800,000
subscribers which was absolutely amazing
thank you guys so much for all your
undying support you know this many
people have got me thinking about how
far we've come as a channel and just all
the videos that we've done together you
know I can remember them just as if they
were yesterday yesterday yesterday
yesterday yesterday oh no it's just if
you want to be 350 me I made this yes
choji's yes Joe Jesus yesterday those
kind of sucked I don't know why you guys
have stuck with me for this long but
thanks at least I was some sort of Sully
you guys are awesome
Oh climb is without you so thanks a
million or should I say eight hundred
thousand Jesus criminy Chris all this
back when I tried to be manly oh god why
is this next in the queue why do they
know me so well we're doing me and my
brother could play together and he would
have a better than any toy I ever made
what am i working with him why why ah
Jesus sags ass oh man Lee how was pole
dancing
oh yeah dancing requires more muscle
strength and coordination than you could
possibly imagine that's true it's hard
as hell yeah I want to do pole dancing
again I want to do another video I'm
probably gonna do with Tyler
Jack how are you shave in the morning
well I just get in a fight with a
mountain lion and let it clawed off my
face a cute look still Amory asks oh why
did I do this holy [ __ ] okay so I made
this video because I wanted to and I
wanted to make a creepy video so if you
want to know where dark applier came
from it started after this video
[Music]
like this I thought that that was scary
so you can see uh and then after it came
this one which is called don't move the
other one was called don't blink this
one's called don't move and I don't know
I just found a bunch of [ __ ] horror
soundtracks and stitched them all
together and then woah know who's in the
background
come on and then like some animal roars
and stuff like that and I don't know is
that the dish so scary I smiled ah scare
only scary people smile
oh no I'm not smiling maybe it was all
an illusion
yeah so that's like it is a fascinating
like look back into what I've done and
it's all boobs super dudes
Oh what's this whoo super juice loop
super juice loop super juice loop super
juice again this goes on room super ten
minute loop super juice I unloaded this
root juice I wasted everybody's time but
I don't regret a dancing rooting for me
Juden broke evening for me to dinner no
kidding I did one more video a Flender
man fall asleep man the most feared
first sketch I ever did now alright
first sketch I ever did and literally
like the wertham Wharf sketch I think
that was out of focus so blender now the
former triumphs reign of terror
the evil reduce to share
it's like with an ill-fitting sumo
ridiculous mustache it's just like it's
hilarious cuz it's it's like added-value
that I did this in my mom's living room
I didn't know how to film correctly and
we had to cut in between two different
ones but I love it oh I love it I love
it I love it I love it I love it will be
so good - you're a fave here oh it was
like trial and error to get to this
point and of course Wade was very
patient and helping me in doing this
[ __ ] like this this is he's just
creeping up behind me
also don't move to Jamaica I wear our
ridiculous way Oh plenty what - don't
take notes frontin all bye
like the most amazing ladies like almond
and this is the first time I ever did
like an outro with an annotation on it
and did that bloopers and everything and
like I was really proud of it I still
have much so proud of this I love this
thing no one can tell me that this is
bad because I loved it and it had heart
and soul and man it was the birth of
wharfs - and good god i felt so good
after I made that I watched this after I
made it and still to this day like I
watch it every once at all I've watched
it probably like Oh 50 or 60 times I'm
not even exaggerating I watched it over
and over you can ask wait I watched it
over and over and over again and I just
I looked at every detail of it and I
loved it so much cuz it represents
everything I've wanted to do and
everything that I have done oh ok anyway
sorry I'm getting super nostalgic right
now I love trying new thing I love doing
new things I love branching out I love
surprising you guys with all sorts of
random weird videos even if it means
that I just slap on a stupid pink
mustache in my American Eagle shirt and
like jeans in a chair that's obviously
my mom's oh it's so good like I love
these things I love doing these things I
love like I love seeing all these like
pieces of history pieces of my history
and people
it's great it's great to me and it's
great to look back because it makes me
remember like where I've come from and
the things that have worked and the
things that haven't worked and it makes
me proud that I love like I've kept all
that up on my channel it's just like
it's my legacy it's where I've come from
it's how I learn to be Who I am today
and it's like in five years I'm gonna
look back at these videos and be like oh
my gosh
I can see me learning to be the person
that I want to be then and it's like
just stepping stones to something bigger
and I love it
anyway this uh this like I said this was
a roller coaster of emotions and it
always is when I look back in my videos
but we hit some of the more we were
awkward ones than I would have normally
done but still it's it's good to see
those two because it's good to see you
like just like that that little sense of
immaturity is still burning bright in my
heart so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this down the comments below I hope you
enjoyed it I certainly did and if you
want to see something else like this I
can review like the year of 2013 and 14
because this was mostly 2012 and 2013
and--but still just as awkward 2013 2014
so there's a lot more cool stuff out
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye